has long been known as a place where
people can explore their wildest and
deepness sexual fantasies I wanted to
find out if that was really true so I've
come here this building may look
innocent but inside lives a dominatrix
who's gonna teach me all about the S & M
arts and we're in luck I'm first try
Holton happens to be my safe word this
is Lady velvet steel hi you are a
professional dominatrix dominatrix
expert and hence banking so this will
definitely do that
you ready spank me oh yeah okay like the
booty boy you are okay anything to
definitely don't want to do like hard
limits well I'm married
so no mocks so Xiomara yeah this is like
for people who really like anal play so
it's like don't have a bin you don't
have oh you are so organized yet very
about
yeah you're all set for tax time what is
this thing you know it because like I
want to play video yes what would you
should I supposed to be a little bit
fearful my fear is for you you may want
to retire after a new deal well the
white anaconda I don't that's surprising
this is fantastic
thank you these are the the whips oh
it's way to hard to hit somebody doesn't
sweetie hot so what do you never that if
you don't hit people usually I would
correct your posture chin up chin up hmm
so that's back back
no stomach I don't like stomach so let's
take this a step further get your shirt
off take the shirt off yes please no you
can fly okay pretty good you know for a
guy in his mid 30s I have a pretty good
luck your thirties yeah they do role
play here in fantasy is a big
let's stop slow okay that just feels
like a pen you're drawing a map of
Alaska again with the nipple all roads
lead through the nipple with you don't
feel sexy with the nipples I don't know
why I'm more of a base of the throat guy
[Music]
hey you're not laughing I like the pain
okay so you're becoming aroused so you
and me 50 euros I see what you're doing
you're posting notes on my nipples
remember to get milk and more fake I
thought I came here for sexy time so far
you've pretty much let should be on my
posture and remove my nipples
[Applause]
how'd you like this I have concerns I'm
hoping that this shape is not what I
think it is and I'm hoping that this is
maybe a chess piece a rook this is a
rook
oh no that's a Bishop's hat was a strong
fits you tough Freitas Oh slave you were
into a ton of trouble now why am I in
trouble the harness broke that's that is
the defective equipment sit down yes
this is an underfunded school what
happened to the harness the harness
broke because if you are talking to me
you look me in the eye
anything else is very impolite I don't
like impolite students understood
understood understood who understood
mistress velvet steel excellent
you're quick Laura I liked off yes smart
boy good
yes very smart what about this student
the harness broke because it was
defective you
that's the one who made a mistake so
it's my fault
the harness broke I'm unhappy we're
getting punished you're going to get up
bend over I am very excited about can't
do that can't lower the pants new
lowering the pants not happening new
[Applause]
nominees Yes No that's a hardwood floor
on top have to be my little doggy a mere
little doggy
I like that good little doggy excited
excellent
sits
[Applause]
you